- That's what we're here to say,
is that we are the new
Black Panther Party.
- [Reporter] What's the biggest
problem facing the movement?
- Well, you know, we
supposed to be in this era
of so-called post-racial harmony
with all people in America,
but us blacks are being
murdered all over the place.
And we get the same treatment
time and time again!
We're not even
second-class citizens.
We third-class!
Stand up black America and
declare to white America
that we aint gonna
take this no more.
Okay!
- [Reporter] Why come
out now and say this?
- You know what?
You had 400 years to
get it right, America.
But you don't know how
to treat your people.
All people, it's
time to stand up!
It's time to take back!
It's time for us to fight back!
And we won't take your
phony words anymore.
We're not gonna do it!
We want concrete results!
You hear what we're saying to
you, United Snakes of America?
What are you supposed to do
when the whole world is watching
and no one is saying anything?
We will not be silent!
- [Reporter] Okay, you, sir,
anything you wanted to say?
- Oh, me?
No, I'm good.